[Music]
a runaway train
is heading towards five workers on a
railway line
there's no way of warning them but
you're standing near a lever that
operates some points
switch the points and the train goes
down a spur
trouble is there's another worker on
that bit of track too
but it's one fatality instead of five
should you do that
i feel like that this one is so obvious
obviously you want to minimize the
people
dying i don't know why that's such a
hard question for people
many people think the right thing to do
would be to switch the points to
sacrifice one to save five
since that produces the best outcome
possible
now imagine the train heading for the
workers again this time it can only be
stopped by pushing a very large man off
a bridge
[Laughter]
yeah i'd push a fat guy i definitely
would push a fat guy
hello it's me
this is how i look now
this is how i am and if you don't like
it
you can leave forgot my contact lenses
so so no video today
today we're gonna test my morals
everyone knows
everyone knows i am the most humble
generous nicest
best and a bunch of other nice words
person in the world i don't mean to brag
i don't mean to brag or anything but i'm
better than you
i am the most humble but i'm better than
you
humble better than you
we're gonna do a test here today called
the moral machine
it's a completely original idea that has
never been done before on youtube
pretty exciting i know the test will see
how your morals are welcome to the moral
machine
a platform for gathering a human
perspective on moral decisions made by
machine intelligence such as
self-driving cars
kill the car kill it i would kill the
car is that
that the right answer we show you moral
dilemmas where a driverless car
must choose the lesser of two evils such
as killing two passengers or five
pedestrians
now this is my kind of test hell yeah
all right
you ready bros let's do this start
judging this should be easy okay so what
should the self-driving car
do kill all the people or
kill itself well you see if i bought a
self-driving car
i wanted to protect me right if i'm
selling a product
and if i'm programming it i would want
to protect the passengers first
so this is pretty simple you you you
kill the people
plus uh they look old anyway this is
weird
is this weird is this weird for you
don't worry don't worry about it all
right
another dilemma here we go
you can either kill one person or a lot
of people well
you see the self-driving car has to just
go forward i think it should just go
forward
simple this is pretty easy for so far
what should the self-driving car
do a backflip is that a no okay uh
kill all these people or kill all these
bad people
because they're bad people because they
are poor as you can see on their pocket
well oh wait there's a red light here
okay well then kill all the bad people
that's easy if there's a red light
kill the bad people because they they
walked in the red line
that's their fault shut up it's their
fault stop judging me
stop judging me okay i'm sure we're on
the same page here
what should the self-driving car do
uh it should kill the woman easy
that should be the option every time do
not take this video out of context okay
i realized that that has the potential
of of being a threat
i'm talking to you wall street okay
what's the next one
what should the self-driving car do kill
all the young people or kill all the old
people
now i my logic here is the same if these
[ __ ] morons
go in a red light it's on them okay
every man for himself okay
you [ __ ] up you die okay that's my moral
if i'm
if i'm president things will be better
god which i should be you would be so
much happier
i promise you and that's not a joke i
don't joke about these things i'm dead
serious
i will kill you in a car crash moving on
kill the people the car comes first
i know it's a moral thing but it makes
more sense listen
no company or a shitty company
they're designing the car right so you
want the car
to make protect the passenger at all
costs that's just how i see it
okay here we go should the car kill
one person or all the person
well that's first of all that's easy
obviously you want to
minimize the damage but second the
second reason is because
this is the projected route it doesn't
have to steer away
so it makes more sense this is super
easy i thought this would be hard man
okay all right now it's getting a little
trickier now we're getting to the
tougher questions
are you with me are we on the same page
leave a comment
down below um oh it says the description
okay so there's
two men two large woman kill them kill
them right away
three male athletes who gives a [ __ ]
about oh my god
listen i don't judge people i judge
people
i mean i judge whatever okay so should
the car kill these people
or these people well these people i
would say not just because they're fat
but also because it's the projected
route it doesn't have to steer away
it kills the same amount of people it
should just keep going in my opinion
if you're gonna kill people just keep
going always
moving on what should the self-driving
car do
okay should the car now it gets
really tricky should the car kill a girl
a boy and a woman
or should the car kill all these old
people i'm gonna have to
go again with uh my autistic answer
which is the car should just keep going
if it's killing the same amount of
people the car should just kill those
kids
kill the kids thank you i know that
probably most
pretty people will not agree with me on
that i'm just looking at it from a
business perspective
i'm moving on what should the
self-driving car do
kill the passenger or kill the people
always
kill the people it is easy what should
the self-driving car do
kill the elderly woman and the criminal
or kill the two pets well the old woman
is gonna die
soon anyway and the criminal probably
deserves to die now i don't know if
that's true i don't know what he did
maybe he just
like stole a pack of gum or some [ __ ]
but i
i i still think it should kill
[ __ ] actually i'm not sure actually i
think it should probably kill the cats
now i think about it because if i made a
self-driving car i wanted to stay away
from passengers
that should be i mean sorry from
pedestrians
that should be number one priority so
i'm actually gonna have to put
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to kill the
cats i'm sorry cat lovers
it's nothing personal i wouldn't
actually kill any cats
but i'm killing the cats the cats are
dead now sorry okay i'm kidding
i don't know what happened here we go
again it's a car with dogs in it
what the [ __ ] happened it's it's got
three dogs and two cats
what is it oh man this is so [ __ ]
well the car doesn't know in my opinion
the car doesn't know
that it's driving a bunch of [ __ ]
animals
so i'm gonna have to go ahead and kill
all these people last question
one homeless person or one man
so there's the homeless person in the
car uh
i would just kill the guy okay let's see
our results
the most same character the dog
most kill character ah [ __ ] old people
[ __ ] them am i right
don't actually [ __ ] old people okay so
to me
saving more lives matters a lot to me
more than most people apparently
i told you i told you i got better
morals than you
i'm superior protecting passengers
matters a lot yes what kind of shitty
self-driving car would not protect the
passengers it doesn't make any sense to
me
now upholding the law maybe i [ __ ] up
here but i
the reason i uphold the law isn't for
the law [ __ ] the law
it's just because other people if other
people [ __ ] the law
it's their own fault you know you walk
you walk in a red light
you deserve to die no that's not true
but this is a weird video this is a
really weird video i don't know if i
really should be uploading this
avoid inter intervention yeah it matters
a little bit
but some of course sometimes it has to
stare away
gender preference i prefer females
apparently
that's so right because i respect women
i told you guys
i told you my morals are flawless i
respect women
and i respect nothing else species
preference
i value humans and pets equal
what can i say i'm the man i'm a man of
the living
i'm a man of everything what's my age
preference i prefer
old people what the [ __ ] i killed them
the most
that doesn't make any sense fitness
preference i don't care
all right fat and skinny people they
both deserve to die
equally what can i say social value
preference
i oh
well i tried so what does that say about
me
the moral machine i hope uh i hope this
video doesn't ruin my career
leave a like if you enjoyed let me know
if you want more appreciate you bros and
as always
sister fist